malgré ce qui est arrivé à loïc moi
j'estime qu'il est juste que je puisse
avoir cette enfant 1983 simone une jeune
veuve s'expriment à visage caché dans
les médias une jeune femme veut pouvoir
profiter de l'insémination artificielle
son compagnon malade avant sa mort lui
avait légué son sperme pour justement
avoir cette enfant à l'époque aucune loi
bioéthique
aucun texte dans ce flou juridique les
médecins du centre d'étude et de
conservation du sperme humain refuse sa
demande d'insémination c'est un problème
qui nous dépasse complètement ce n'est
plus un problème médical
c'est un problème de législation et donc
on se tourne donc nous mêmes vers les
législateurs demande effectivement une
loi les journalistes s'interroge est ce
que c'est un prolongement de loïc pour
vous je sais que c'est la dette question
dangereuse et moi je ne vois absolument
pas comme ça la société est divisée
des débats sont organisés sur les
plateaux télé le monde médical
n'arrivent pas à se mettre d'accord et
le gouvernement s'abstient de toute
déclaration
un an plus tard en 1984 le comité
consultatif national d'éthique et mis en
place dans le but de rédiger une loi et
la machine législative et bien lente
face aux progrès scientifiques
la même année une autre femme corinne
fait elle aussi une demande de
procréation post mortem
depuis six mois corinne 21 ans implore
l'objet de sa demande d'obtenir le droit
d'avoir grâce à une insémination
artificielle
un enfant de son mari mort à 24 ans d'un
cancer
six ans plus tard une troisième demande
mais toujours le même flou juridique
une femme at elle le droit de récupérer
le sperme de son mari décédé pour faire
un enfant
la question s'était posée en 84 elle se
repose aujourd'hui à toulouse
elle se repose parce que les
législateurs n'ont rien fait pour
combler le vide juridique mis pourtant
en évidence il y a 6 ans il faudra
attendre 1994 soit onze ans après la
première demande de procréation post
mortem
pour qu'un texte de loi soit votée sujet
le plus sensible la procréation médicale
assistée
la loi exige que la femme soit en âge de
procréer et interdit tout fécondation
avec le sperme du mari décédé
le texte est clair la procréation post
mortem est interdite en france
une interdiction renouveler lors des
différentes révision de la loi
bioéthique
[Musique]